political intolerance becoming a serious
problem in America it always has been
unfortunately just hours after
Republican senator Ted Cruz got
viciously booed at Yankee Stadium his
appearance on The View went completely
off the rails it got so bad the ladies
of the view even came to his defense
inflation has one cause and one cause
only
in inflation in the United States has
one cause and one cause of it we do
cover climates
ladies ladies excuse us let us do our
job let us do our job we hear what you
have to say but you gotta go they're
accusing us of not covering uh climate
change and we do that almost well
and it didn't end there moments later
the producers had to use the bleep
button and immediately cut to commercial
when I think for the vast majority of
Americans the answer is no
[Applause]
this is I think where we have sort of
landed and it it's on both sides here I
think this is disgusting it's
reprehensible I give the ladies of the
view a lot of credit for how they behave
Dana how would you have handled this if
you were there oh as opposed I would
have been bleeped 100 I if I you mean if
I was interviewing Ted Cruz and somebody
interrupted like that they're ridiculous
and they're they're children and they
should be arrested and do time in jail I
really think that they should cash and
and no cash bail for these people who
are interrupting things it's it's absurd
and their parents have got to be
embarrassed by their behavior and you
know Ted Cruz one he's a good sport he's
willing to go on the show he's got a new
book coming out he obviously wants to
publicize it the ladies of the view are
willing to have him come on and to be
treated like that as Preposterous Jesse
would you would you treat someone like
that or have someone treated like that
on Prime Time never if whoopee wanted to
come on my show I wouldn't yell at her I
would listen
and then I would laugh at her
and I think that's more effective
a lot of liberals
they want to live in a one-party state
where it's like Vladimir Putin gets 99.9
percent of the vote they say they're
pro-choice they don't want choice they
want one choice they want the Democrats
they don't want to hear from Republicans
at all now if you're yelling at the view
to get them to cover climate change have
you ever tried to yell at a woman to
change your mind it doesn't work I have
tried it for years and you never were
permission to say this
yeah they're not going to book Al Gore
tomorrow okay Al Gore can't even get Al
Gore booked
the last time I was on The View I used
to co-host it uh frequently the last
time I was on uh it was a screaming
match and uh Whoopi Goldberg threw me
out of the building okay yeah and my
book went to number one on the New York
Times that weekend so thank you Whoopi
um look I don't know who decides who
gets into that audience but make no
mistake if you're a guest there I know
people have been guests they can insist
on having X number of people in the
audience I don't know what the eels
there are but what I can tell you is
this you've got an audience that to some
extent has been primed by The View I
mean they are always they are very
anti-republican they are progressive
leftists and so this is Their audience
so I don't know what they're surprised
at
let you close I was on Greg's show a
couple weeks ago and got heckled just a
little bit near one thing Greg shut
everybody down and so we don't Heckle
um you know that's the right way to do
it and I we give them a little we give
them a little stuff every once in a
while there in a few but I thought that
I was impressed with how they handled I
was equally if not more impressed with
how Senator Cruz handled it
I actually thought that was a nice break
from the normal chatter right did you
notice how the audience didn't even they
couldn't tell the difference because
generally it is a it is a screaming
match and so you have them the audience
basically joining in that stuff it has a
reverse effect like it's making me more
militant in my adherence to fossil fuels
and to red meat it's like I see that I
go well I'm gonna just start eating a
raw rib eye while driving a
tractor-trailer up a mount Nicole just
like this the whole time I'm not
stopping I'm coming for you you but you
you you you're right it's all uh it's
too it's there it's not it's actually
not right versus left that's left versus
left yes yeah that's the kind we want
yeah I'm going with pugnacious hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else